FOX NEWS ANALYST, RAYMOND
ARROYO.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Kaleigh: GOOD TO HAVE YOU
HERE.
THE CDC’S UPDATED GUIDELINES
DOMINATING THE NEWS CYCLE AT A
TIME WHEN THE PRESIDENT IS
FACING CRITICISM.
FROM THE RESPONSE TO THE MIDDLE
EAST TO THE HANDLING OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE FORMER ASSISTANT HEALTH
SECRETARY UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP,
ADMIRAL GIROIR SAYS THIS ABOUT
THE QUESTIONABLE TIMING.
>> LOOK AT THE WHIRL WIND THAT
HAPPENED ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT.
DR. WALENSKY WAS INTRANSIENT IN
HER POSITION.
YESTERDAY MORNING DR. FAUCI SAID
YEAH, YOU STILL NEED A MASK
INDOORS AND OUTDOORS IF YOU’RE
IN A CROWD.
BY THE AFTERNOON, IT WAS ALL
OVER.
THESE DECISIONS ARE NOT PURE
SCIENCE.
SHOULDN’T LOOK AT IT THAT WAY.
IT’S NOT ABOUT INFECTION
CONTROL.
IT’S ABOUT OPENING AMERICA,
LIBERTIES AND HOW WE RUN OUR
COUNTRY.
THERE WAS NO SCIENTIFIC
KNOWLEDGE THAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY.
IN FACT, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
CDC WEBSITE AND THEY SAY WHAT IS
THE SCIENCE BEHIND IT?
IT GOES TO AN APRIL 2 WEBSITE.
>> Kaleigh: HE’S RIGHT,
DR. SAPPHIRE.
I KNOW ADMIRAL GIROIR
PERSONALLY.
I WORKED WITH HIM IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
HE’S SOMEONE THAT HAS BEEN
TOTALLY GROUNDED.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE TIMING?
TOO LITTLE TOO LATE?
>> YOU KNOW, IT’S INTERESTING.
I WAS COVERING IT LIVE YESTERDAY
WHEN THE ANNOUNCEMENTS WERE
MADE.
WHEN THEY WERE ASKED THE
QUESTION, YOU KNOW, WAS THERE
NEW SCIENCE THAT CAME OUT OR IS
THIS JUST BECAUSE OF POLITICAL
PRESSURE?
THE ANSWER WAS NO, NO, NEW DATA
CAME OUT.
SHE QUOTED A COUPLE OF STUDIES.
I WAS LIKE I REMEMBER READING
THAT IN APRIL.
ADMIRAL GIROIR IS CORRECT.
THE DATA THAT THEY HAVE REFERRED
TO HAS BEEN OUT A COUPLE MONTHS.
IT BEEN CONSISTENT.
THE CDC HAS BEEN ABOUT TWO TO
THREE MONTHS BEHIND THE DATA
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
YOU KNOW, I CAN TELL YOU, IT’S A
GREAT FOOD FORWARD BUT I DON’T
THINK THEY WENT FAR ENOUGH.
THEY CONTINUE TO IGNORE THE
SCIENCE WHEN IT COMES TO THIS.
THEY’VE HAD TUNNEL VISION ABOUT
GETTING TO ZERO CASES AS A
DETRIMENT.
WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO AT THIS
TIME, GET US OPEN.
THEY’RE ONLY ADDRESSING THOSE
VACCINATED.
PRESIDENT BIDEN PUT OUT A
DANGEROUS TWEET YESTERDAY.
HE SAID IF YOU GET VACCINATED,
TAKE OFF YOUR MASK.
IF YOU DON’T, YOU HAVE TO KEEP
WEARING A MASK.
THAT’S NOT TRUE.
HE IGNORED THE UNVACCINATED, THE
CHILDREN, THOSE THAT HAVE
CONTRAINDICATIONS TO VACCINATION
AND WHAT ABOUT THE MILLIONS THAT
HAVE RECOVERED WITH NATURAL
IMMUNITY?
WHAT ABOUT THE RELIABLE DATA
THAT SHOWS NATURAL IMMUNITY FROM
INFECTION PROVIDE JUST AS MUCH
PROTECTION AS THE VACCINE?
THEY CONTINUE TO IGNORE THAT AND
THAT IS EXTREMELY IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> Kaleigh: THAT’S RIGHT.
DR. SCOTT ATLAS HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT NATURAL IMMUNITY FOR SOME
TIME.
THEY TRIED TO RUN HIM OUT OF
WASHINGTON D.C.
LOOKS LIKE HE WAS EXACTLY RIGHT.
RAYMOND, COMING TO YOU.
I FOUND THIS THOUGHT TO BE SO
INTERESTING.
THE SOUND BITE DEFENDING
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S WEARING OF A
MASK FROM WHITE HOUSE SENIOR
ADVISER FOR COVID RESPONSE, ANDY
SLAVITS.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID AS RECENTLY
AS WEDNESDAY.
>> I’M NOT SURE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS THE AVERAGE PERSON.
I PERSONALLY THINK THERE’S A LOT
OF PROTECTIONS AROUND THE
PRESIDENT.
WHY DOES HE NEED SECRET SERVICE?
HE’S A VERY IMPORTANT PERSON.
I THINK YOU SHOULDN’T TAKE YOUR
MARK JUST BY WHAT YOU SEE IN THE
OVAL OFFICE.
MOST PEOPLE, IF YOU’RE INDOORS,
AROUND OTHER PEOPLE VACCINATED,
THE CDC SAYS IT’S OKAY.
YOU SHOULD LISTEN TO THE CDC ON
THAT.
>> Kaleigh: SO THE LEAD COVID
ADVISER SAYS TO US THAT BIDEN IS
SO IMPORTANT THAT HE NEEDS TO
WEAR A MASK WEDNESDAY.
THURSDAY, THE MASK GUIDELINES
ARE RESCINDED BECAUSE NONE OF US
ARE IMPORTANT AND NOW THE
SCIENCE IS ON THE SIDE OF NOT
WEARING THE MASK?
>> THIS IS LIKE WHEN BIDEN CAME
IN, WE WERE TOLD SCIENCE IS
BACK.
AFTER WATCHING THIS PLAY OUT,
I’M THINKING OF WHITNEY HOUSTON,
STEAL THE LINE "THIS SCIENCE IS
WHACK."
OKAY?
NONE OF THIS ADDS UP.
THE PROGNOSTICATIONS ON THE
SPREAD WERE WRONG.
AT CHRISTMAS TIME, THEY SAY
SCHOOLS AND RESTAURANTS AND GYMS
WOULD BE SUPER SPREADERS.
NONE OF THAT HAPPENED.
AS DR. SAPPHIRE SAID, WHAT ABOUT
THE NATURAL IMMUNITY OF OUR
CHILDREN?
YET TODAY YOU HAVE THE CDC
LEADERS THAT DR. WALENSKY ON
"THE TODAY SHOW."
SHE SAID IT WILL BE HARD TO LET
GO OF MASKS.
PEOPLE WANT TO WEAR THEM.
WE SHOULD DO THAT.
IN THEIR OWN TIME THEY’LL LET GO
OF IT.
WHEN DID MASKS BECOME PETS?
THAT’S MY PROBLEM IN THIS.
IMMUNITY AS DR. SAPPHIRE SAID,
WE DON’T HEAR ANYTHING ABOUT
T-CELL IMMUNITY FROM THE CDC OR
THE INNATE IMMUNITY OF THE
CHILDREN.
THE IDEA THAT YOU SAY VACCINATED
PEOPLE CAN GO ABOUT THEIR
BUSINESS AND TAKE MASKS OFF, BUT
CHILDREN IN A PLAYGROUND OUTSIDE
HAVE TO BE MASKED?
THAT’S WHAT DR. FAUCI SAID
YESTERDAY.
NONE OF THIS ADDS UP.
IT MAKES YOU FEEL THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS BEING HORDED FROM
US.
ONLY LEAKED OUT WITH POLITICAL
INTENT AND WITH A POLITICAL
EDGE.
BASICALLY TO BLUNT THESE OTHER
STORIES THAT ARE SWAMPING THIS
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Kaleigh: I HATE TO TELL THE
CDC DIRECTOR, IT WON’T BE HARD
FOR ME.
I MAY HAVE A BONFIRE IN FLORIDA.
>> ME NEITHER.
MINE WAS GONE.
SO IT WAS AN EASY PARTING.
DE-COUPLING.
>> Kaleigh: GILLIAN, I WORKED IN
THE TRIP ADMINISTRATION ON
OPERATION WARP SPEED.
I REMEMBER BEING IN THE OVAL
OFFICE WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
WATCHING HIM PUT IMMENSE
PRESSURE ON THE OFFICIALS AROUND
HIM, THE SCIENCE OFFICIALS
SAYING WE HAVE TO GET THIS
VACCINE OUT.
DO IT SAFELY.
WE HAVE TO NOT LET REGULATIONS
STAND IN OUR WAY.
HE PLANNED FOR PRODUCING THE
VACCINE IN ADVANCE.
IT WAS REMARKABLE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION GIVES
LITTLE CREDIT WE’RE AT THIS
POINT.
WE DON’T SEE THEM GIVE CREDIT TO
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION.
>> WE DON’T.
IN LARGE PART IT’S THE NATURAL
TRANSITION FROM A REPUBLICAN TO
A DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAVE ALSO SEEN THE WHITE
HOUSE KIND OF GO OUT OF THEIR
WAY SOMETIMES INCLUDING WHAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT SAID DURING THE
FIRST WEEK OF THE ADMINISTRATION
WHICH WAS THAT WE HAD
ESSENTIALLY NO VACCINE ROLL-OUT
PLAN WHEN THEY CAME TO OFFICE,
WHICH THE NATION KNOWS IS NOT
THE TRUTH.
IF YOU GUYS WILL BEAR WITH ME A
SECOND, I WANT TO ASK
DR. SAPPHIRE A QUESTION.
I DON’T KNOW IF THIS IS A
CLEAR-CUT QUESTION, BUT I’M
BRINGING IT UP BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT IT.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TWEETING ME
ABOUT IT.
THEY’RE SAYING THERE’S A LOT OF
AMERICANS THAT FOR THEM, FOR
MEDICAL PRE-EXISTING MEDICAL
REASONS, A VACCINE IS NOT AN
OPTION AT ALL OR IT NOT AN
OPTIMAL OPTION.
CAN YOU TALK TO US BEFORE WE
START SHAMING EVERYBODY NOW WHO
DOESN’T HAVE A VACCINE, TALK TO
US ABOUT SOME OF THE MEDICAL
CONDITIONS OUT THERE THAT WILL
PREVENT REASONABLE-MINDED
AMERICANS NOT JUST BECAUSE
THEY’RE BEING ANTI-VAXORS BUT
BECAUSE THEIR DOCTORS AND
PHYSICIANS RECOMMEND THAT THEY
DON’T GET IT.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THAT.
I DON’T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> IT’S IMPORTANT TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN THE
TRADITIONAL ANTI-VAXERS AND THE
VACCINE HESITANT.
THE VACCINE HESITANT, I
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY HESITATE.
THERE ARE SOME MEDICAL
CONDITIONS WHERE IT NOT
NECESSARILY CONTRAINDICATED TO
GET THE VACCINE BUT THE TRUTH
IS, WE DON’T HAVE A LOT OF DATA
ON IT, SPECIFICALLY THOSE WITH
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED SYSTEMS AND
AUTO IMMUNE DISEASES.
THOSE THAT HAVE SEVERE
ALLERGIES, THERE CAN BE A
CONTRAINDICATION THERE.
THE COLLEGE OF RHEUMATOLOGY SAID
THEY RECOMMEND PEOPLE WITH AUTO
IMMUNE DISEASES GET THE VACCINE.
THEY STARTED TO SEE UPTICKS IN
THE FLARES OF THOSE WITH AUTO
IMMUNE DISEASE GET THE VACCINE.
HERE’S THE CONVERSATION THAT
PEOPLE NEED TO GET.
WE HAVE TREATMENT FOR A LOT OF
THINGS.
WE STILL DON’T ACTUALLY HAVE A
SILVER BULLET IN TERMS OF
TREATING SEVERE COVID-19.
SO THIS IS THE CONVERSATION.
RISK AND BENEFIT WITH YOUR
PHYSICIAN.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULDN’T SAY YOU
HAVE TO WEAR A MASK UNTIL YOU
GET A VACCINE.
IT’S DANGEROUS AND
IRRESPONSIBLE.
THIS IS A CHOICE THAT NEEDS TO
COME BETWEEN THE PATIENT AND
THEIR PHYSICIAN.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT AND THE
CDC NEED TO STAY OUT OF IT.
>> IT’S ALMOST LIKE THE
PRESIDENT SAYING THOSE WITH
PRE-EXISTING MEDICAL CONDITIONS
THAT MIGHT NOT WANT TO GET THE
VACCINE WILL HAVE TO BEAR THIS
SPECIAL BURDEN THAT HEALTHY
PEOPLE WON’T HAVE TO, IS THAT
RIGHT?
>> IT’S A DOUBLE EDGE SWORD.
THOSE WITH CHRONIC MEDICAL
CONDITIONS ARE AT A HIGHER RISK
FOR COVID-19.
THOSE ARE THE ONES WE’RE SEEING
HOSPITALIZED.
AGAIN, THERE’S BEEN SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE VACCINES WITH
PEOPLE WITH CERTAIN CONDITIONS.
I WILL SAY THE DATA TODAY DOES
NOT SHOW EXACERBATION OF THESE
CONDITIONS AND THEY’RE PROVING
TO BE SAFE IN EVERYONE.
AGAIN, IT’S OKAY TO BE HESITANT
AS LONG AS YOU HAVE A
CONVERSATION AND EDUCATE
YOURSELF.
IF YOUR PHYSICIAN RECOMMEND
AGAINST IT, I DON’T THINK IT
FAIR FOR THE PRESIDENT OR THE
CDC TO SAY YOU HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO WEAR A MASK.
IT’S THEIR CHOICE.
THEY KNOW THEY’RE AT AN
INCREASED RISK.
>> THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT
UP, GILLIAN.
EMILY, TO YOU.
I WANT TO HAVE YOU BUTTON UP
THIS SEGMENT FOR US.
YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT THE LEGAL
MORASS THAT SOME OF THESE
GUIDELINES CREATE AND HOW ONE
GOVERNOR IN PARTICULAR, A GOOD
ONE, HAS A SOLUTION FOR THAT.
>> Emily: THAT’S RIGHT, GOVERNOR
DESANTIS IN FLORIDA HAS NOW COME
OUT AND SAID THAT HE’S GOING TO
GRANT CLEMENCY ESSENTIALLY AND
EVALUATE ANY PENDING CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST ANY BUSINESS
OWNER AND OPERATOR THAT IS
SEEKING CHARGES FOR REMAINING
OPEN DURING THE LOCK DOWN.
THAT’S FANTASTIC.
I’VE BEEN ADVOCATING FOR THIS.
THE DEEPER UNDERLAYER OF THE
LICENSURE AND REGULATION.
THERE’S SO MANY CASES STILL
SIMMERING.
LET’S TAKE SUNDAY RIVER BREWING
CO IN MAINE.
THEY WERE THE MOST INSPECTED
RESTAURANT.
THEY HAD THEIR LIQUOR LICENSE
TAKEN AWHY MULTIPLE TIMES.
THEIR HEALTH LICENSES TAKEN
AWAY.
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING OFFICER
SAID THAT THEY WERE AN IMMINENT
THREAT TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
THEIR DOORS REMAIN CLOSED.
THIS IS AGAINST THE BACKDROP OF
IN MAINE, 55 COVID DEATHS.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE FAMILY
DEPEND ON THE BREWERY FOR THEIR
LIVELIHOOD?
58.
LET’S GO TO STATEN ISLAND
CONSIDERED AN ORANGE ZONE THERE
IN NEW YORK STATE.
AN OWNER WAS ARRESTED AND
LICENSES TAKEN AWAY.
THE OWNER FACED 25 CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
THIS IS AT HOMICIDES ARE AT 75%.
DOESN’T THE STATE HAVE MORE TO
DO?
WHERE I AM HERE, THE OWNER OF
FARM BOY RESTAURANTS FACED FINES
OF $2,000 A DAY WHEN THE REASON
THEY WERE STAYING OPEN IS
BECAUSE THEY COULDN’T AFFORD TO
CLOSE.
IT’S ALL OF THESE LICENSURE
RESTRICTIONS, THE HEAVY FINES
AND THE YIELDING OF A WEAPON BY
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THAT I
HOPE ALL OF OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS WILL EXPUNGE MOVING
FORWARD BECAUSE THERE’S A LOT
MORE PEOPLE SUFFERING THAN JUST
THE GOOD PEOPLE UNDER GOOD
GOVERNOR DESANTIS’ WATCH THERE